we've got to show you the danger and the
damage from storms that roll through the
south twisters touched down in multiple
states yesterday including areas hard
hit by last week's storms several people
were hurt but no deaths have been
reported that's good news more than 100
000 homes and businesses lost power at
least 40 tornadoes touched down
yesterday now the severe weather is now
marching towards the east coast oh no
the weather channel's jim cantori will
show you where it's headed in just a
moment but first we're going to go to
janet shamley and she's in mississippi
just south of memphis with more on the
story janet good morning looks pretty
quiet right now
gail hi good morning to you it's quiet
right now but i have to say these storms
have left behind a trail of debris and
damage we are in south haven mississippi
it's just south of memphis and there are
power lines down here and the warehouse
behind me has had its roof just peeled
back like a tin can this morning all
across this region people are waking up
to a big cleanup
a few stairs all that's left of a
mississippi home ripped from its
foundation overnight two people inside
are safe rescued by family
near gulfport debris littering
neighborhoods after a tornado touched
down there the whole house was shaking
you could just hear ripping apart
and we came and saw everything's gone
the storms also raged in the florida
panhandle and in alabama where the
storage facility was torn apart near
mobile
at least one confirmed tornado
as a series of powerful storms slammed
the south on wednesday we're looking at
the sky
high winds wrecking this mississippi
warehouse
in arkansas a bird's eye view above
springdale where an ef-3 tornado ripped
apart homes and a school winds topping
130 miles an hour it was just like a
loud train like right close to you in
louisiana a close call south of
shreveport when this tree crashed
through a home missing a sleeping baby
by inches
in lafayette this car crash attributed
to the gusting winds only minor injuries
the walls are cracked the roof's gone
the storms pounding many of the same
communities still reeling from another
system just last week
so it is the spring storm season here
but this is the second time some of
these very same communities are dealing
with damage and once again a loss of
power tony
janet thank you very much